[Música]
Hola soy María Clara calle y les doy la
bienvenida a este nuevo capítulo de
medio ambiente hoy hablaremos de dos
proyectos mineros que han provocado que
las manifestaciones se incrementen por
un lado los activistas no pudieron
impedir que lucheras un pueblo de
Alemania fuera destruido para ampliar
una mina de Carbón mientras que en Chile
algunos celebran que el proyecto domina
haya sido suspendido primero veamos Qué
pasó en Alemania
el epicentro de la batalla climática se
perdió Luther un pueblo en el noreste de
Alemania será destruido para que el
gigante energético rwe amplíe una mina
de Carbón a cielo abierto que explota el
ignito el plan existía hace años y la
guerra en Ucrania lo impulsó los
alemanes se volcaron a los combustibles
fósiles para depender menos de Rusia
país al que le compraban el 45% del
Carbón que importaba
hoy queremos presentarles un acuerdo
sobre nuestras centrales eléctricas de
Carbón porque tenemos que asegurar
nuestras necesidades energéticas debido
al cese del suministro de gas Ruso y
también debido al cierre de las
centrales nucleares francesas a cambio
del pacto con el Gobierno Federal y el
local la compañía Se comprometió a dejar
de producir electricidad basada en
carbón para el 2030 8 años antes que el
plan nacional y también firmó que cinco
pueblos quedarán intactos con lo que
cambian los planes originales de
destruirlos para ampliar la mina de
Catch
pero luthera no se salvó el 11 de enero
la policía empezó los operativos para
despejar la zona las protestas
incrementaron y el 14 de enero la
reconocida activista greta thunberg se
unió a los más de 15.000 manifestantes
que llegaron allí tres días después fue
detenida temporalmente y otras 150
personas enfrentan procedimientos
legales
Aunque rw defiende el proyecto diciendo
que el ignito contribuye a palear la
crisis energética los activistas
critican que esto va en contra de las
promesas ambientales del país
se molesta especialmente que los
partidos que tienen una orientación
ecológica no haya luchado más
intensamente para detenerlo aquí donde
está el carbón
y que reconozcan claramente que seguirán
cavando aquí y luego pasarán por encima
de los 1.5 grados Alemania
tiene casi la mitad de su energía de dos
tipos de Carbón la antracita que es la
que más dióxido de carbono emite al
quemarse y al dignito que aunque produce
menos CO2 que el resto de las cuatro
clases de carbones es más contaminante
que el gas y el petróleo otro de los
grandes descontentos es que los
ambientalistas consideran que el partido
verde los traicionó en el acuerdo de
coalición que firmaron en 2021 los
verdes los socialdemócratas y los
liberales se trazaron una ambiciosa meta
eliminar idealmente el carbón a 2030 Y
si bien los planes en la minailer van
hasta ese año los ambientalistas no
perdonan que el proyecto minero haya
destruido úlcera y tampoco que el carbón
se haya impuesto una vez más
y mientras los activistas ambientales se
lamentan en Alemania el panorama es el
opuesto en Chile allí el proyecto
Dominga fue suspendido este pretendía
explotar hierro y cobre invirtiendo
2.500 millones de dólares también
querían construir un megapuerto y una
planta desalinizadora a pocos kilómetros
del archipiélago de Humboldt uno de los
ecosistemas más importantes y también
más productivos del país el comité de
ministros de chile hundió el proyecto y
la empresa andes Iron apelará en 24
hablamos con Lizbeth vanderberg
directora de Ocean a Chile para
comprender la importancia Ambiental de
la zona hay que entender que la
corriente Humboldt que es la que tenemos
en Chile va de Sur a Norte Entonces al
norte de estos proyectos está la reserva
más antigua es de chile que es donde
habitans de Humboldt pero también
las ballenas y también está toda la zona
de reproducción de locos y de Machos
Entonces por ejemplo un derrame de
hidrocarburo
una planta de exhaladora que que
devuelva en las plantas de sanadora lo
que hacen es devolver agua pero también
alto contenido de salmueras al agua eso
acabaría irreversiblemente con eso
ecosistema el comité de conformado por
seis ministros un dio temporalmente del
proyecto Dominga porque la compañía no
presentó información suficiente para
evaluar los impactos ambientales Esta es
una pelea legal de más de una década en
2006 descubrieron hierro cobre y oro en
la comunidad de la higuera cuatro años
después andes Iron compró el proyecto y
en 2017 tanto el comité de evaluación
Regional de coquimbo como el comité de
ministros rechazaron el proyecto por
mala calificación ambiental luego el
caso va y vuelve entre el tribunal
Ambiental de antofagasta y la Corte
Suprema de chile finalmente la máxima
instancia pasa de nuevo el caso al
comité de ministros y por segunda
después Este grupo hunde el proyecto
y mientras las instancias políticas y
jurídicas definen Qué pasará con Dominga
los ambientalistas piden que se declare
área Marina protegida en el archipiélago
para defenderlo de los proyectos minero
energéticos que existen allí ahora
Nosotros hemos dicho no sin número de la
única forma de proteger el archipiélago
secretando un área Marina protegida de
múltiples usos porque hay que recordar
que este no es el único proyecto que
está ahí cierto hay bastantes otros
intereses de hecho desde el año 2010
cuando se baja una termoeléctrica que se
llama barrancones esa fue el primer
proyecto que se baja la zona por su
importancia biológica después vinieron
dos termoeléctricas más ahora un
megapuerto y hay otro megapuerto que se
llama cap que también está situada en la
zona entonces este tiene un gran interés
y creemos que estos intereses hay que
cerrarlos para siempre en esa zona por
ahora el proyecto minero Dominga está
suspendido hasta que otra entidad diga
lo contrario así llegamos al final de
nuestra Crónica vea más 24.com nos vemos
[Música]